i
do
look fantastic and mesh
happy thursday everyone
so i often wake up to the same thing
every morning larry kudlow asking me if
he can use my toothbrush
and i say yes but i also wake up to a
question in my brain whose apartment is
this
where are my pants
but also does politics make people
stupid or do stupid people flock to
politics it's really the old chicken and
egg question except here nobody wants to
eat nancy
or joe
or beto for breakfast
first there's beeto speaking of chicken
an unemployed career politician who
crashed a press conference put on by
grieving leaders in law enforcement a
day after the texas mass shooting only
to grandstand for political reasons this
guy has the political instincts of idi
amin and pol pot combined
excuse me
you're out you're out of the line i'm in
an embarrassment
sit down
shooting is right now and you're doing
nothing no we're off
[Music]
see beto is a tragedy freeloader
it could have been a personal injury
lawyer but he lacked the integrity
he saw a horrible event and thought how
can i benefit from this as you know he's
running for governor of texas after
failing that before and failing a bunch
of things including a sobriety test
the only thing he doesn't fail at is
making an ass of himself
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so yesterday he puts on his hello kitty
backpack jumps on his skateboard and
heads to a place where he could make
himself the center of attention he's the
essential opportunist rather do they do
any hard work he just finds ways for
others to do the work for him he gives
tom sawyer a bad name
like when he married a rich lady so he
doesn't have to get a real job
hell it worked for john kerry
but it begs the question
it begs the question why didn't i think
of that
stupid
then there's our president who couldn't
read a room
if it was a book called a room
that's an improvement
amidst a countrywide crime wave what's
he do he craps on every cop he pushes
the police reform bill because it
happened to be the two-year anniversary
of george floyd's death yes he exploited
the calendar for political symbolism
while people and kids included continue
to be killed in cities like chicago and
philly you might call him tone deaf but
he wouldn't hear you
but the media and the dems don't give
about other crime because they might
have to blame themselves instead joe
signs an executive order that targets
policing as america once again preps for
a violent summer all because he couldn't
let an anniversary go to waste
and yet he says nothing about the after
effects of floyd meaning the rioting
it's like commemorating the anniversary
of hurricane katrina but not mentioning
the destruction it did after
it had to be about the cops and because
joe's got almost no working memory left
he assumed you do too
by falsely claiming that republicans
opposed any reform on policing he's
either lying intentionally or he refuses
to take his prevagen
the house passed a strong bill
it failed in the senate
or our republican colleagues
opposed any meaningful reform
that is of course
for democrats filibustered police
reforms proposed by senator tim scott a
black republican or as liberals might
call him a white supremacist
in 2015 after the shooting of walter
scott i wrote a bill to fund body
cameras
last year after the deaths of brianna
taylor and george floyd i built an even
bigger police reform proposal
but my democratic colleagues blocked it
i extended an olive branch i offered
amendments but democrats used a
filibuster to block the debate from even
happening now imagine if they had
listened to scott life might have been
better by now we might have unified a
country with low crime and high spirits
but they didn't want that they didn't
because they didn't want republicans to
lead the way the dems are like the
really drunk guy at the party who
insists he doesn't need a ride home from
you to get home
and of course ends up crashing
it's how they work it's not about a
solution it's making sure the
republicans have no part in it so
they'll take your misery over any reform
right joe
we needed to reform
reform uh not deform and not with the uh
the squad girl said
defund we're not gonna defund we're
gonna refund okay i'm gonna give you a
refund
uh a reset
a redo
a dee doo
doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo do do do do do do do
do do
do do
do do do do do do do do do do do do do do
do do
do do
do do
do do
do do
hey knock it off
of course
of course the reason why biden did this
executive order is due to a narrative
that's already come apart at the seams
like one of stelter's sofa cushions
we were told by dams in the media that
police were overwhelmingly targeting
unarmed black males when actually was
the criminals they let out who were
doing most of the targeting and data
shows police were less likely to use
lethal force against black than white
suspects of course the professor behind
the study was cancelled faster than
chris wallace's corporate credit card
good for you
i can't help it i'm gonna fight that one
i know i can't i'm a jerk that's not to
say cops were in the right all the time
and what happened to floyd wasn't
seriously wrong but when you look at the
billions in damages and lives lost over
this misconception it's beyond belief
that anyone could think pushing this lie
was worth it well except for the
democrat party who saw an election in
their grasp
and now what do we have well violent
crimes have increased anywhere from 5 to
40 percent in some of america's biggest
cities compared to the same time frame
in 2021 and it's this murder search that
disproportionately affects black victims
meanwhile former president barack
obama's attempts to link this week's
mass shooting in texas to george floyd's
murder but the two are as unrelated as
woody allen and ronan farrow
yeah
that's a good one on fire yes how does
making that connection help it doesn't
how does that lead to unity it doesn't
it's political symbolism and let's face
it the dems are really good at it you
could say they invented it you could
also say it's the only thing they could
invent they suck at everything else
especially uniting a country
welcome tonight
yes she loves america so much uncle sam
filed a restraining order former state
department spokeswoman morgan ortega
he's our go-to guy as in going to buy
mothballs
post the fox across america jimmy fella
[Applause]
she's like fine china white fragile and
can't be put in the dishwasher
we've tried fox news contributor cat tim
and his knuckle sandwich is bigger than
a party sub my massive sidekick in the
nwa world television champion tyrants
jimmy jimmy you have outdid yourself
outdone you've even ruined the way i use
verbs
it looks like a monkey threw up on you
like just shards of
mucus and banana
and with your hair like what came out of
my nose after that sinus surgery
apparently this is where all the baby
formula went yeah
jacket
all right so his name is robert francis
but we call him beto what do you call
him oh i mean that that video is a
rorschach test if you watch it and you
go hey this guy's a
you're great but if you watch it and go
way to go beto you're
you understand
that's it right there you know i hate
it's like nothing i hate more than
self-promotion and i was having this
conversation today on my nationally
syndicated radio
i saw that coming like a frisbee in the
desert it was for you
trucker
there are so many jokes to be made about
beto but do you know how like really
disrespectful no it is that is there are
parents in that room
that literally lost their kids true and
he has shown up to make it about him it
is not a round table discussion of how
to solve the problem it's hey grieving
people here's what we know here's how we
cope and beto shows up with like hey
look at me you know so it was really
pathetic but it was nice to see him get
sent home by somebody besides the voters
yeah
he's just the worst he's just the worst
one
ever do you remember when he ran for
president beto i always say this he's
like the mumford and sons of politicians
every time he runs people are like you
know you got to listen to mumford and
sons and it's it's cool to say you do
yeah but then you turn it on and you're
like what is it you know what i mean
and that's bait out it's buffered so
it's that bad tyrus no i i don't know
i'm i'm just so proud of him he turned
dirty paper towels into a jacket
[Laughter]
what do you do you think it was bad
timing on biden's part to do this uh uh
the commemoration even though it was
exactly two years to the day
of course it was bad timing and it was
it was bad politics everything about it
was bad i just like the one thing about
the beta o'rourke thing
i think sometimes when people do this
we
we fall for the bait i wish abbott would
have said
please come up let's hear what you have
to say yeah
when someone crashes and their whole
purpose is to crash good point
you you can't fall for it get out of
here get out then the bickering fight he
wins yeah the next time something like
that happens where someone like if
someone was to crash
please take the floor let's hear your
ideas i can't wait to hear this solution
right he would have had nothing to say
yeah
and then after a few minutes of
standing there going oh
and he was spewed off some and maybe now
the adults now continue right right it's
over but now he we're we're talking
about we're talking about it yeah you
know even and you know how i feel about
barack obama but
you can never bring
that together yeah it was it was grossly
irresponsible
the children deserve their own tweet
their own moment their own day
nothing
comes in between that and
unfortunately we're going to have a
summer of more retirements
less policing because
you took everything out of what mr scott
did
and you only put in the bad things
anyone reads it it's a bad it was a bad
day for policemen yesterday it was a bad
day for americans yesterday and our
politicians did nothing to help yeah
so morgan you just got back from ukraine
how was it uh about as intense as uh you
know the past few days here it was
actually i was on the plane on the way
back and i got the um
the notification uh that there was a
mass shooting at an elementary school
and i was with orphans in ukraine that
had been rescued by a national based
group actually um and i'd spent you know
a few emotional days trying to hug and
love on these orphans who had been
through you know a war-torn country and
i saw that notification on my phone and
i just turned my phone off and i thought
i just can't like i knew it was going to
be horrible i knew it was going to be
devastating um and so it's a
horrifically sad thing to come back to
and as you just said tyrus more sad
because you just look and know that no
one's even gonna offer real solutions
it's just like politics
the moment after it happened well i
think what happens is that there is
no desire to do anything unless there's
a political
point to be gained because there are
actually solutions to tim scott's been
trying yeah exactly yeah yeah whether it
is mass shootings or just rampant
ongoing crime there is stuff you can do
but uh you know now it's just uh
you know who can you said it best on the
five you absolutely said it best
sometimes we need to just shut up yeah i
say that when geraldo's on
uh
almost all the time
yeah it's not we yes it's just you need
to and then it's hey punk yes
so kat um did you support the police
reform are you glad biden pushed it
there's certain things i like like i i
don't like no knock warrants i think it
still doesn't address things that need
to be addressed like unconstitutional
drug laws and those sorts of things
um
i also kind of liked the betto video you
did but you are yeah
bad guys i liked it because
i liked it because it proved to me that
i am not as self-involved as i thought i
was like
i would never do that
i bet you dated guys like that in
college
um
no
actually like like what like not like
that no no no no no unemployed
jobs
possibly a bass player say they're
keyboard though that's worse
uh but also you just picture like he
practiced that if you think it's
cringe-worthy to watch just think about
him like on the way there he's
definitely a practices in front of the
mirror guys oh who is it
you got to start practicing in front of
people yeah so someone can go no is that
is that what mirrors are for you would
just think that at some point along the
way he might think you know what maybe
maybe i don't do this yes but he did it
but he doesn't know what to do next
that's a terrible position to be in
because he's got to either run for
office or get into reality television
yeah but i just love that we're all
acting so shocked that the guy who
streamed his dental visit made a weird
video that is true that is true
attention as much as i thought i did
yeah you still have room to grow yeah
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else